Kill Bill give it to me come on
okay so that snow was made out of soap
so and then as a when you are doing that
kind of
um like sword fighting you don't pick up
your feet you slide
so because you know you're sort of
sliding along and the beginning part
with the Bowing was something that
was introduced to me by the trainer and
the choreographer so I introduced it to
to Quentin to ask him if that was okay
to do because I thought it was kind of a
moment because you know even though
we're both Warriors we respect each
other you know and so that was the kind
of kind of a a nice moment between us to
sort of acknowledge our you know just
how
excellent we were at what we did before
we sort of took each other out